this is the culmination really of a
six-week battle between
peloton interactive the company that uh
floated on the stock market a year or so
ago and has
achieved cult status really with a lot
of investors and followers
and the consumer product safety
commission which is the main
watchdog in the united states
responsible for overseeing
businesses that sell items to the public
now what happened on
the 18th of march was that pelleted
admitted as you say that a child had
been killed
following an accident with one of the
treadmills but they refused to
instigate a product recall they also
quibbled very very publicly with
the regulator the uh cpsc about the
number of incidents that had been
involved the cpsc made clear that they
thought there have been around 70
incidents or injuries involving the treb
plus and uh
right throughout this whole saga peliton
have said that was misleading and
inaccurate and they were playing down
the number of uh incidents that have
been involved in an attempt to see off a
recall well today they've caved in and
said that there will have to be
a recall so the product can't be sold to
the public anymore now interestingly
this isn't this is not a cheap item
it retails in the united states for
around 4295 dollars
hundred around three pounds in this
country it was sold as you were saying
earlier by
invitation only to uh members of peloton
it has some 3.1 million members right
around the world
and uh so it's really not very clear
just how many people
have bought this piece of kit as i say
it is not a cheap piece of
equipment and it's also not known how
many of them are on sale in this country
either bear in mind this is an american
product recall since then the company
has been besieged by
lawyers trying to instigate class
actions because it's had an impact
on the share price and i can tell you
right now peloton shares are down by
some six
and a half percent following this news
which as i say represents something
of a capitulation to uh the america to
the regulator responsible here
now interestingly if you dig around
there are quite a lot of accidents that
involve treadmills not just the uh tread
plus as i say this is a particular
incident that involved one child
of whom little is known by the way other
than a report that was in the new york
post
a short while ago which said that the
child involved the injuries were
very unusual that was the highly unusual
that was the terminology that this
source
to the new york post used but i can tell
you uh
the uh statistics on the treadmill
injuries in 2018-19 alone
in the united states there were some 17
deaths as a result
of treadmills not the peloton treb plus
here but
all treadmills and during that period 22
and a half
thousand americans had to visit accident
and emergency
as a result of uh misuse of a treadmill
so
it's a it's a grown-up piece of kit
needs to be taken seriously but as i say
this is a major capitulation on the part
of peloton
interactive the statement from the chief
executive john foley
says the decision to recall both
products was the right thing to do for
peloton's members and their families
i want to be clear peloton made a
mistake in our initial response
to the consumer product safety
commission's request that we
recall the tread plus we should have
engaged more productively with them from
the outset
and for that i apologize today's
announcement reflects the recognition
that by working closely with the cpsc we
can increase safety awareness
for our members so a major climb down
from peloton the shares are falling as i
say by some six and a half percent and
that statement really does look like a
bit of an attempt belatedly to cover the
company's backside with the regulator